the deadline to file your 2017 taxes was
last night at midnight so tax season is
now officially over
so congratulations that's a nice thing
this of course means all over the
country right now tax accountants
finally get to relax and cut loose I'm
sure they're all taking today off and
celebrating okay you're next to the
sagging all right impersonator all right
I can see we've got a couple of
accountants here tonight glad to see you
guys out having a good time
thanks bro but you know what make this
time even better if we could do a shot
with our personal hero [ __ ] on let's do
this Coco I can't Canada now can't do a
shot I'm in the middle of a show I'm
sorry oh how about instead of a shot I
just breastfeed you coz you're acting
like a friggin baby a shot fine
congratulations on another tax season
finished all right
[Applause]
thank you all right ladies and gentlemen
we have a great show tonight we're gonna
have a really good hey Conan yeah what
now you know what get this show off the
heezy
if you our hero Conan would solve for X
what do you mean solve for x
oh snap bro are you thinking what I'm
thinking bro if you're thinking Conan
should solve the Pierce Birkhoff
conjecture one of abstract algebra is
most elusive mathematical formulas then
hell's ^ yeah Wow Wow okay guys I'm
sorry this is a really complicated math
equation I can't solve this oh oh do you
need a sprig of rosemary and a light
dusting of cornmeal because you sound
like a chicken Conan I'm not gonna do
something just because you called me a
chicken yeah well you know who'd say
that a chicken
[Applause]
okay Z minus y over Z squared yeah Z
minus y over Z squared how's that okay
Oh Conan I'm sorry to say but you
freakin nailed it bro Conan is the math
to Punk gonna get out with myself thank
you
probably got a great show tonight gonna
have it's rific time a lot of good stuff
happening hey you can continue with your
show
listen Conan if you really want to party
with us you got to do one more thing
don't eat a pint of blood to a hurricane
stricken victim of Puerto Rico like a
pimp no I just don't need a blood two
days ago it's not safe to do it twice in
one week so hey I feel you Conan let me
ask you when you donate it did you find
out your blood type was P for [ __ ] all
right I'm not sure how any of this has
got to do anything with partying and
accounting it's tax-deductible dingus
April 19th ever yeah guys is this really
how accountants celebrate the end of tax
season oh we have no idea
we're not accountants wait you're not
even accountants uh we just spin signs
outside an accounting firm on Ventura
Boulevard
Vasquez E Vasquez one hour tack service
and bail bonds baby
[Applause]
you